and we should say congratulations
euforio you won an emmy hey
i know
um
and that was the
that was that kind of proper lockdown
lockdown yes so where were you i was in
my living room okay i was in my living
room and it was um it was actually
really special because i think you know
had it not been done that way that year
i wouldn't have been able to have my
whole family with me so i did it in my
living room
my mom's back there you can't see in
this picture but her face is like this
my nieces my little niece my dog
runs out from under the table when
everybody starts screaming um it was uh
it was really really special so i got to
share with them which i couldn't imagine
doing that any other way and if i had
done it
all like in a real
like audience like this in front of
everyone i would have i'd i would just
would have
probably thrown up i don't know what i
was like
i was so nervous but this was the one
wasn't where so
how many there must be five nominees
yeah i think i believe so five nominees
best actress in a drama yes um but there
was someone outside everyone's house yes
in a hazmat suit that like looked like a
tuxedo it was actually really cute um
but what's not cute is everyone
no matter like all the nominees someone
would be in front of their house in the
hazmat suit with an emmy
and if yeah like that
and if you didn't get it
they would just
drive off
this is a breakthrough role for you jack
because
an american accent
yes yes i was doing an american accent
what in that clip yes olivia
i feel
you see
what a lot of actors do when they do an
american accent
is they tend to just go for like one
region of america and they commit to a
single american accent i decided with
this role that i would take sanitar
around all 50 states
sometimes in the same scene i thought
why just do one when you can show off
the mall
i would start the scene talking like i
was from new york and then all of a
sudden i'm suddenly speaking like i'm a
cali girl and by the end of the scene
they're stopping me because it sounds
like i'm from the dukes of hazzard
i'm all over the place but i thought you
know just show off your skills i was
particularly pleased that the first
story you ever told on the show about 20
years ago is in the book it's the one
where uh you'd park on a double yellow
line for a few moments do you know the
story oh yes yes well that that had its
repercussions of course because well i i
mean i parked on a double yellow line in
shaftsbury avenue it was um the day of
the state opening of parliament
and i rushed up to give a take a tape
and audio tape because you know i do
audio tapes to my agent and i came
downstairs there was a policeman
pasting um a parking
ticket on my windscreen
and i was just furious because i'd only
been there for a minute and so you know
i tore it off the windscreen and i said
you've got a dick that small
because i thought the best thing is to
insult him as quickly as possible of
course and he took umbrage
he didn't like it and he arrested me
for uh breach of the piece
and uh parking on a double yellow line
and um then he called for help from
other policemen and there were lots
about because it was the state opening
of parliament and you know they're
mingling around and so um i was taken in
a in a police car to beau street police
station
and um there i was arraigned
and um
they said
empty your handbag and i had a few
things in my handbag and one of them was
a packet of peppermints but they're
wrapped in silver paper you see and that
the detective
in charge thought that it was drugs
and he said um
you know what if we got here then that's
interesting and i said it's just a
packet of peppermints officer
and he said no i think we better check
you out matron and he got the um the
matron to come and
uh put me in a room
privately and i knew
i knew because i was sharp
that she was going to give me an
internal examination i just knew that
nothing had been said but i knew it so
when she locked the door she went out
for a bit i took all my clothes off
immediately
well you would you know you know you're
going to be examined
and she came back in and she said
you've been here before
[Laughter]
i said i have not been here before she
said yes you have how did you know to
take your clothes off
and i said well i know you're going to
examine me aren't you they called you
matron so i knew something was afoot
so
um
she said anyway bend down or lie on the
couch or something and
she
examined me my front body and my back
and of course they thought i wouldn't
like it
[Applause]
congratulations
tuesday night three brits
do they do they give you the wink do you
know at all i knew i'd won one of them
not gonna lie i know i better the other
two no i didn't oh nice surprise i know
yeah
i'm really happy and i don't know if
anyone will noticed on tuesday night
when you were sat on the piano singing
at microphone in right hand i thought
left hand didn't move as much as normal
it seemed heavier
as if i would ever tell anyone if i was
or wasn't
i'm not laughing
it's very like yeah i have to say as a
casual observer it looks like you
[Laughter]
all are
okay
i'm taking that as a yes
when a friend is on the show i feel bad
bringing it up because you know you kind
of think life has moved on
but you
do bring it up you do recreate things on
your socials like the famous uh turkey
scene
uh this you know and you know yeah
so you decided to really do this
anything for the gram
yes i did put oh god i'm such an idiot i
i don't you know people say aren't you
supposed to be kind of mysterious or
aloof or it's like that's isn't it
instagram just to be a yourself so i'm
pretty goofy but yes i decided it was
thanksgiving i was going to put a turkey
on my head and that's not a real turkey
i didn't know where to get one like that
so i did excuse me to all the vegans i
put a real turkey on my head oh my
goodness
what did i tell you it was so gross
you tell us why we watch this because
it's not as easy as you'd think no uh
here we go
uh obviously vegan discretion advised
so now what have you put on your head
a towel and then i also had like a
little plastic oh girl oh no
there was music playing it looked better
than this
but now you had a special butcher in to
help okay so i when scream there's a
girl named melissa barrera who i love
and we became really good friends she
came over with her husband who's a
butcher
that's what it looked like afterwards
and i ate it
we begin with bad news because you were
meant to be here in the studio yeah i
was meant to be there with you and i'm
really sad not to be able to be there
today yeah right
no truly because i love traveling with
pedro when we are promoting a film i
love your show i love london it was
gonna be a short
nice fun trip but
wasn't possible oh well well it's lovely
you're here in zoom land that's terrific
but there is disappointment among the
guests uh james i know you were looking
forward to meeting penelope again i
nearly left
this is why i was here
to smell you um
just to be near you
uh yeah but you have met before we've
met a couple of times yes yeah i
remember we met at the bathtub
yes we did
i was very excited to see you
uh i was presenting the best actress
award and of course you want it because
you're the best actress
yeah she won and uh don't look so
surprised
you probably directed her because you've
done like 90 of her film and um as she
came towards me she went i am so glad
that it is you and i was
of me like
in that show
i know what you do
she goes i'm so glad this year but i'm
so glad you and as i presented her the
bafta i kicked her really hard in the
toe
i don't remember that you don't no but i
promise you next time i see you i will
be able to do your accent and i will
invade you okay
i i love it and do it brilliantly or do
it badly i love it either way i must say
we've got a picture of you backstage at
the baftas and uh
just look at james here he i mean you
look like the cat that got the lipstick
you know what when i was younger for
some reason my lips used to go
incredibly light and people would always
say to me are you wearing lipstick and
i'd be like what but yeah you're not
wearing lipstick i'm not uh
there's this isn't no of course this
isn't this water but so there are you
know there are set twos you have some
tetchy moments and words and once you
kill them but
can we talk about the sex scene it's one
of the best sex scenes i've seen in
forever oh that's sexy who put that
together yo seriously
[Applause]
it's not like they're kind of like
prancing around naked it's just it's a
really
clever
so who who put did you guys put that
together did ricky scott put it together
no we had nothing to do with that
excuse me i'm just trying to
cover my universe over here
and of course it's not just you in it uh
other screen legends jeremy
jeremy
jeremy was particular
[Applause]
he was great he was behind the camera
why are you having sex
i heard you talking somewhere in there
how your height difference makes those
stunts more complicated thank you graeme
i didn't say it didn't destroy it
now is a good story it's like a story
well you see there's there's a
particular stun i don't know if it's in
this but there's a you know he
spider-man swings us on top of a bridge
and he places me there
that's
so
he's supposed to gently you know rest mj
on the bridge and walk away from her
it because of our height difference i
obviously if we're on the same like
point
we were attached i would land before him
my feet obviously hit the ground before
he does
so
what would happen
well
there's like it's called a bottom mark
isn't it and the bottom mark is to
basically it's a thing that they do in
stunts that is basically designed to
stop you shattering your kneecaps so
zendaya would land and i'm the superhero
i'm supposed to look cool and she would
land and then i would sort of land like
this and my feet would swing from
underneath me and then she would catch
[Laughter]
you're me very very lovely about you
were like oh my gosh thank you
it's so nice to be caught for a change
oh my gosh
you also appeared in now
what is one of the biggest films of all
time a spider-man no way home
everyone loves it everyone loves
spider-man yeah
i want to see in the cinema and when you
guys appeared the cheer was amazing yeah
and can you use something
you know you went to school it was so
cool yeah i mean it's so i you know i i
finished playing i'm i'm far too old to
be playing spider-man now but they they
asked me back and and it says the
sweetest thing ever um because i put
that to bed i was like no that's i'm
good i'm done that's that's lovely um
and tom holland is just the best so i
just kind of became a fan again and then
and then they asked me to do it and and
toby was doing it as well i have it's
toby's i'm i've got to do if toby's
doing it
and at least you're at the oldest
exactly
but he's my but he's my spider-man so
it's like you know i i would practice
his lines in the mirror when i was in
drama school like that was very high at
the time
my friend terry mcginnis who and he
would he would crack up and he would
look at me like yeah you'll never play
spider-man andy and uh and then and then
here we are and uh
but me and me and toby we um we became
friends and we
we snuck in
to a theater in los angeles um
on the opening weekend and we were just
two you know middle-aged white guys in
baseball hats and masks and we just kind
of yeah absorb the most yeah you know
special special things in the middle of
a pandemic and it's one of those things
i mean when you've had a big success in
a role like that
going back to it did it feel like a high
risk thing to do it was a stupid idea it
was a really really scary thing to
attempt yeah especially just the costume
38 year old men in a spandex unit they
are unforgiving those questions they are
intimidating very intimidating
[Music]